[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARCO DELLA TORRE: We're going
to go through our experience,
how we got to be on GCP,
and what our experience has
been when we got there and all
the things that we learned.
We're also going
to talk about, I
guess, some of the things we
might have done differently
if we had our time again.
So there'll be plenty here
for everyone, I think.
Really happy to be here with
a couple of my teammates.
I'm Marco Della Torre, I'm
the CTO of Derive Systems.
Over in the blue
shirt is Scott Nelson,
who is our Director of Software.
And DJing this event
is Jim Martens, who's
our Data Science Team Lead.
So we're going to
have some really fun
demos from these guys,
talk about architecture,
and also, just get a sense
of how we fit in the world.
I thought I'd start out
just letting you know what
we're going to be up to you.
A bit of a primer
on our industry.
We're an automotive IOT,
so we put little devices
inside vehicles that
do really cool things.
They're LTE connected,
they collect
all sorts of data from
vehicles, and they also
rewrite the software
of vehicles.
One of the things that sets
us apart is that we do vehicle
write access to make vehicles
more capable than when they
get to you from the factory.
We'll talk a bit
more about that.
Give you a sense of what
the market opportunity was
that we went after.
Obviously, do some fun
demos, because that's
what everyone's here to see.
And then talk a little bit about
the tips and lessons learned
that we had from doing all this.
We'll start out a little bit.
I'll talk a little bit
about our industry,
just give you a lay of the land.
For those of you
who are about to
or have already started building
an IOT platform, a lot of this
is going to apply directly.
This will just give
you a surface layer
of how our customers
are special to us.
But obviously,
all the firmware--
cellular connectivity,
mobile apps, the data flows--
that's probably going
to be really familiar.
And we hope it is,
because we want
you to learn as much from
our experience as you can.
This is a little bit
about the history
that precedes us at Derive.
Really dates back a
number of decades,
as things started to become
connected and smart and
digital.
So starting out with,
going to the PC.
And more recently, our
connectivity becoming
linked to smartphones.
Even our homes going smart.
Our doorbells are smart now.
This is one of my favorites--
our ovens are smart now.
It's pretty cool.
Shout out anyone from June
Oven who's in the room.
I think the only one that tops
that is this-- our toothbrushes
going smart.
This is really something that
the social media networks are
trying to sell me right now.
I haven't seen
toothpaste go smart yet,
but I think that's
probably next.
The question is, why is
the biggest appliance
in our lives, maybe one of our
biggest assets in our lives,
also one of the least smart,
connected, or integrated?
And that's these little
guys on the right hand side.
Why are these things
static after we buy them?
We get to choose the paint,
maybe a couple of options.
We drive them off the lot.
They never change again.
In fact, they drive off
the lot not even knowing
how we're going to use them.
Are we going to be using
them for law enforcement?
Or for delivering packages?
Or picking up groceries?
Or dropping the
kids off at school?
The OEMs don't know, so they
build them all the same.
Little bit about the
industry we play in.
Moves very slowly.
There are about 270 million
vehicles in operation in the US
today, so a lot of
vehicles on our roads.
Each of those vehicles has a
lifespan of about 11 years.
So if you do that math,
it takes a real long time
for the industry to change.
The vehicles that
roll off the lot today
are going to be out
there for a dozen years.
It's going to take 15,
20 years for the industry
to change the entire set of
vehicles that are on our roads.
Just to highlight
that some more,
the first modern vehicle
appeared around 1901.
You can debate what
modern vehicle is,
but that's about right.
We have about 95 years of that.
'96, the first electric
vehicle happened.
Here in Silicon Valley, we
think a lot about Tesla.
We hear a lot about
Elon and his folks.
Man, it's been more than 20
years since electric vehicles
started.
And now, they're a little
over 1% of the industry.
So this industry
moves really slow.
While it's moving slowly, we
love the idea of everything
going autonomous and
electric and maybe flying
or who knows what.
The reality is, these
vehicles are out there
with incredible
networks of processors,
running software
that we can upgrade.
So what we've gone
about to do at Derive
and what we offer to
consumers and to fleets
is the ability to modify
the software inside vehicles
to make them mission specific.
So that means, whoever
uses that vehicle,
we'll give you the software
that does that mission best.
OK.
It's something we've been doing
for consumers for a long time.
It's something that
we just recently,
in the last few years, started
doing for enterprise fleets.
And we're the only
people that do it.
And we do that
through an IOT device
that goes in the vehicle.
And that's a real big
differentiator for us,
because we're the only ones
that write the software.
We're going to talk
about the platform
the powers that
differentiator for us.
Just to give you a
sense of why this works.
If any of you out there ever use
a Fitbit or a health device--
I built one of those one time.
Yeah.
Humans.
Really difficult to change
the software of you guys.
So we think about this in
terms of enterprise fleets.
What's happening out
there are devices
that are collecting information
about vehicles, so for example,
how fast the vehicle's
going or who's driving it.
Fleet managers are
coaching drivers--
like, hey, I see you're
speeding out there.
Be great if you didn't
do that tomorrow.
It's just like the Fitbit,
like, hey, 9,000 steps
today, how about 10,000?
Really hard to change
the habits of humans.
So we're out there trying
to coach these drivers.
Drivers are doing the right
thing about 50% to 80%
of the time.
And by the way, each
year, about 20% to 30%
of the drivers in a
fleet leave, so you
get to start again
with that 20% to 30%.
So it's really tough
to win this battle
in the automotive industry.
I think the biggest thing
that drives failure here
is that these behaviors are
at odds with operational KPIs.
So if you think about
drivers in a fleet
that have to make a
number of stops each day--
you got to make
eight stops today.
Sorry, I'm not picking on you.
You're just the closest to me.
You're going to make eight stops
today to get your paycheck.
But you're not allowed to speed.
If you get to stop seven, and
it's almost the end of the day,
guess what you're doing
if you get to stop eight?
You're breaking that
speed limit all day.
So one of the challenges is that
operational KPIs are directly
at odds with how people
drive the vehicle.
So because we have write
access to the vehicle,
we're thinking about
this in a different way.
We modify that the way
the vehicle operates,
so it doesn't matter
how you drive it.
So for example, I can stop
that vehicle from speeding.
You can put your pedal to the
metal, it's not going to speed.
Here's a case study the talks
about these three things--
saving lives, lowering
environmental impact,
and technology that
pays for itself
for these big appliances.
This is a big major national
fleet that we work with.
Let me just walk you
through this real quick.
There are two lines
here-- orange and blue.
Apologies those of you
who are color blind,
but I'll walk you through it.
It will be obvious anyway.
The blue line represents
our control group.
These are vehicles that we
didn't upgrade the software on
at all.
And as you can see, over
time, being the bottom axis,
these people keep speeding.
Speeding violations
just continue.
And these folks were
coaching their drivers,
telling them not to
speed, pleading with them
not to speed.
And humans just keep speeding.
The orange line is a test group.
This is the set of
vehicles that we modified.
And you can see, at the start,
they weren't doing so well.
They started out in a similar
place, they sped a lot.
We upgraded the software
of those vehicles
so they wouldn't
speed at a level
the fleet deemed unacceptable.
As you can imagine,
if the vehicle
can never exceed that speed,
violations go to zero.
So that's the difference
between trying
to change the software
of humans and changing
the software of vehicles.
Bit of a video about us.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
That gives you the
lay of the land.
So for those of you who
are building IOT platforms
or thinking about building
building IOT platforms,
that's the world
in which we live.
Building IOT devices that
go inside vehicles that have
a really unique differentiator.
That are connected.
This is our product
market opportunity.
Think about your product
It's going to fit a
lot of the same things.
In our case, we deal
with these vehicles that
are running generic software.
We live in a commoditized
telematics industry.
This is just folks who are out
there measuring GPS location
and not able to write
to software of vehicles.
That's about an $18
billion industry.
We brought mission specific
vehicle software upgrades.
That's our big differentiator.
But of course, we
also offer telematics
and all the commodity
features, as well.
We built a platform
that goes after this
and brings it to market.
And we're going to walk back
through how we got to that.
But ultimately, combining
those four things
meant three key features
for our customers one
being fewer collisions.
Just drivers out there
having fewer accidents.
And if they're having accidents,
they're much less severe.
Secondly, having a
smaller carbon footprint.
We reduce the amount of
gas that vehicles use,
which has a huge
sustainability benefit.
And lastly, lower costs.
By reducing the amount
of gas that fleets
are consuming in their days,
they're spending a lot less.
Actually pays for the
technology itself.
So a nice little
market dynamic there,
where by making the fleet
less expensive to run,
they can afford to buy our
technology and then some.
When we looked about this
product market opportunity
and selecting a
cloud vendor, there
were three main
criteria we looked at.
First was speed to launch.
We saw this huge market
opportunity in this $18 billion
market with this unique
engineering capability,
and we wanted a
partner that could
support us to get right into the
market as quickly as possible.
We wanted to go capture
this thing while we were
the only ones that could do it.
Second thing, we were getting
huge market demand signals,
because no one else was offering
this to enterprise fleets.
So we wanted a partner
that could scale with us.
Not just launching
quickly, but then
being able to meet the
demand that came with that.
And lastly, we're
putting connected devices
inside huge machines.
This has got to be secure from
board to cloud and back again.
These were the three
main vectors for us.
And obviously, we chose Google.
I'm going to kick
it over to Jim.
Jim is going to talk about
how we went from, really,
nothing to standing
up our first fleets.
Our fleets typically send about
20 million data points a day.
And Jim had to stand that up
from scratch, making it happen.
So Jim, over to you.
JIM MARTENS: Hopefully
I'm coming across.
I had to move the mic.
I learned about a term
called beard noise.
Maybe still getting
a little bit of that.
It's really impressive all
the tools that Google and GCP
provides, especially to
those that are trying to get
started with IOT.
The communication to IOT--
some of you may know, I know
some arms went up in here
earlier, but it is MQTT.
There are open source libraries
through PAHO and documentation
on getting devices registered
and set up in the cloud
really quickly.
It was important to us to get a
proof of concept and have data
coming from-- whether even
they be virtual devices--
and getting those
pushed in the cloud,
and have just that
pathway established,
to understand how we would
take that same technology
or that same methodology
and bring that over
to the firmware.
For this particular-- I
won't go too deeply into it,
but I'll take one of these
open source Python files
and slightly modify it and
then send some data up.
Currently, just to
show end-to-end.
We'll first off take--
one thing that's nice about
this particular Python script
is that it establishes
the MQTT connection
and sends that data up into the
cloud that we can then verify.
Like I said, it will
change a few things
when it comes to
the data payload.
This data payload is
very particular to us.
It's something--
the types of things
we care about, especially
when tracking a vehicle.
So we're talking about
latitude, longitude, speed,
those types of things.
We're not going to
get too creative,
but we will update the time.
And maybe we'll change
the latitude, as well.
Or we can change the course
in this particular time.
All right.
So again, this script is
simply going in and pushing up
the payload that we've selected
for a given virtual device.
And then, we would
like to verify
that that data has gone up.
Here we have our
demo next device 19.
Now, our process for this is
sending data into BigQuery.
It's from BigQuery
that we pull all data
for analysis and
any other processes
that we're going to do analytics
further on down the road.
As you can see, we've recently
sent the most recent message.
The data, we know,
is coming through.
This is not just
helpful for proving
that we have a simple data
pipe going from end to end,
but this proves
particularly useful
when you're doing development
further on down the line.
When you're trying
to do testing,
trying to do any
sort of scaling,
testing, anything
along those lines,
trying to do it here
before you're actually
trying to push these changes
into something much more
complex, such as firmware
or these IOT devices that
are inside vehicles.
Of course, the GCP
console gives you
access to many, many
things, from being
able to track devices that
are inside your system
or being able to track
monitoring of said devices.
Of course, we went from
a development environment
to looking at what is actually
production for a fleet that
is in existence that is sending
out up to 20 million messages
in a given day.
You're able to monitor the
traffic for MQTT traffic,
device operations, errors,
which are luckily quite low,
byte traffic, and what
is the billable data that
is being sent across.
In our particular model,
we're sending already
to the IOT Core.
And then that data
is being processed
by server-less functions,
or Cloud Functions,
as the case may be.
Again, we tend to see a
similar kind of pattern
in this case, where we get
to see the traffic or Cloud
Functions that are
being instantiated
over the course of a week.
For ourselves, we
see that there seems
to be a particular
kind of pattern.
And this is particular
to our IOT use case.
In which case, we have
drivers that are in a fleet,
and their typical traffic
is peak for midday
across the United States.
And then in the evenings, we
see quite a decrease in traffic.
For ourselves personally,
even though these devices
aren't sending on a
quick, regular basis,
as if they were actually in
traffic or actually moving,
our devices still send data,
even when they're not active,
necessarily.
Just let us know where they
are and how they're doing.
And then, if we look at
something on the weekend,
we see less traffic, which is
pretty expectable, one hopes.
Again, there's a wide
range of information
that you can pull from
different cloud platform--
graphs and charts.
Understanding how many different
instances are being served up
to handle the kind of traffic
that's coming through.
One thing that's
really important to us
is looking for spikes.
Spikes are what tell us that
possibly something's going
wrong.
Or there's something that
when we're sending data,
whether it be the BigQuery
or a third party endpoint
for collection and
other processing,
it's those spikes that let us
know that there's a problem
and alerts us to
some sort of action.
Another important
tool, especially
if your data s being passed
through Cloud Functions,
is to watch.
For any errors that
might be going across,
they require further
investigation.
A lot of the times, when you're
sending 20 million packages
in a day, you're
going to get errors,
whether that be possibly
internal connection
errors, where you're
trying to save the data,
or external errors to where
you're trying to send the data.
One thing that's really
powerful about IOT is that,
or Pub/Sub, which is
what IOT feeds into,
is that if a message doesn't
reach its end point, if there
is an error, it isn't lost.
It's sent back to the beginning.
And generally speaking, this
is what you see with spikes,
is that the data didn't
reach its end point,
and it's gone back to
the front of the queue
and will try to go
again at a later time.
Metrics and ability
to observe what's
going on within the
system goes much deeper.
And typically, this
is within Stackdriver.
Stackdriver allows you to
set very specific parameters
on what you may be wanting to
watch, whether that be BigQuery
reads, BigQuery writes, or
anything within the entire JSP
platform that you
need to monitor.
What's more powerful than that
and has proven useful time
and time again is being able to
set alerts within StackDriver.
Such a case might be that
SQL usage is reaching a point
that it might cause problems.
And people who've
developed on GCP
know that there are
set limitations,
resource limitations
and API limitations.
And you can set
alerts and policies
within StackDriver that allow
you to know a problem before it
occurs, before it
stops and causes
problems within the system.
And with that, I'll
pass it back to Marco.
MARCO DELLA TORRE: Awesome.
Shameless round of applause
for Jim for a live demo.
Brave.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
So that gives us a sense of
just how we went from zero
to getting the back end going.
And we'll come back to the
architecture a little bit.
Scott will walk us through that.
But once we got the back end
working, got the data flowing
in our system to support
this volume for our fleets,
we started to build
the user experiences.
So obviously, building
the data flows is great,
but customers have to have
something to work with.
So here's some examples
of things that we've built
and we're building
for our customers.
Obviously, starting out with
web and mobile data, ways
for drivers to interact
with the system, as well
as fleet managers, through
dashboards and visualizations.
We offer distracted
driver prevention,
so when the vehicle
comes out of park,
we lock the phone
down, so drivers can't
be sending SMS or making calls.
It's one of the leading
causes of collisions.
We just take that
right off the table
by making sure that if they're
in Drive or they're in Reverse,
they're not texting.
Seat belt enforcement,
we're really excited about.
This is one where it prevents
the vehicle from even starting
until the seat belt is on.
We know that most
collisions in a fleet
happen within a really small
radius at the start of a drive.
That's also the time when
you're least likely to have
put your seat belt on yet.
And for a driver in a fleet
that's making eight stops a day
or 12 stops a day,
it gets a hassle
to take that seat belt, put
it on and off every time.
They tend to skip that.
Well, that's why
they get in accidents
and hurt themselves and others.
So we're taking
that off the table
by making sure that that
seat belt's on every time.
And lastly, dynamic
speed governing.
We can offer fixed speed
limits for vehicles,
so that vehicle just never
goes above a certain number.
We're starting to do dynamic
speed governing, as well.
So looking at the location
and heading of the vehicle
and applying the speed
for that road or a speed
relative to that
road to the vehicle.
Nobody needs a delivery vehicle
doing 100 miles per hour
down their street to
get to the next stop.
We stood up the back end.
We started to build
the user experiences.
And it took off.
We work with many of the
nation's largest fleets
now, including one
of the top five.
And that one fleet generates
about 20 million data points
per day and has more
than 25,000 vehicles.
So even as we just started
to build this thing,
the demand was there.
And it's only taken off since.
So going up to that higher
level of experiences--
turn it back to
Jim and show us how
we turned that back end of
IOT Core and Pub/Sub data
flows into user experiences
for our customers,
JIM MARTENS: Of course,
just establishing the data,
getting from point A to point
B, isn't entirely that useful.
BigQuery proved to be
one of our best tools
for identifying devices
in the field that
might be causing problems
or just not behaving
as we expect them to do.
Identifying individual
errors with logging,
while at times was
useful, it didn't
give us the kind
of insight to help
us dig on particular issues.
Being able to find
specific vehicles
and how they're behaving
was a simple thing
to do within BigQuery.
There are other types of queries
that proved to be quite useful,
like trying to identify
devices that haven't reported
GPS in some amount of time.
All these devices that
we have, they have LTE,
they have Bluetooth, and
have GPS connections.
So whilst your phone
may also have GPS,
the device is supposed
to be reporting
its GPS at the same time.
There's a number of reasons that
that might not be happening.
You may be in the city scape or
a valley that doesn't have GPS.
Or at the end of
the day, the driver
takes the vehicle and
parks it in a garage
or gets taken in for services.
And so for all
intents and purposes,
this device disappears
to the fleet, possibly.
So being able to find these
vehicles that aren't reporting
as we expect them
to is something
that's particularly important.
We can then go in and
try and track down what's
happened to those devices.
Now, all these tools are
very useful for ourselves,
internally, while we're in
this development process,
while we're trying to go
through the steps of setting up
this fleet of 25,000 vehicles,
or any fleet that we're
working on.
But it doesn't really add
much value to the user.
As Marco said, that's what we're
really trying to drive towards,
is get something that's useful
for them for tracking data,
for being able to track their
fleet, manage their fleet,
gives them real value.
We were able to do this
relatively quickly with, again,
using just a Google product.
Being able to pump
data from BigQuery
into Data Studio, which allowed
us to, without using BigQuery,
and it's something that's a
better tool, even internally,
in some cases, being
able to track down
specific vehicles, when
they last reported,
when they last pulled
information that they
were expected to pull.
But then, we wanted
more than that.
And so for that, we
needed to elaborate
on our architecture a bit.
Back to the slides.
SCOTT NELSON: Thanks, Jim.
This is Derive's Google
Cloud architecture.
It's simple.
But when we started,
it didn't feel simple.
For us, we had excitement.
We had confidence.
But we didn't have experience
for building architectures
that will handle 25
million messages a day.
We took a very iterative
approach to this,
as Marco and Jim has mentioned.
And I highly recommend
building this in layers
and building layers upon it.
It's the strategy we did
during development, trying
to get to market quickly.
And it's the strategy we
leverage for our roadmaps
and for further
capabilities that we have.
And I would like to
walk through the flow
and highlight some of
the big milestones,
starting with our
device in the vehicle.
So as Jim initially
demoed, a big milestone
is working on your
ingestion and storage
and getting this set up
in a proof of concept
to really start seeing
your data that you
wish to flow through the cloud.
And get the tools that you
need to really visualize it.
This was empowering for us
from a development perspective.
This let us check off a lot of
architectural considerations
that we had.
IOT Core really proved out
the scalability and security.
And Pub/Sub, with
the reliability,
being able to handle data spikes
that we see from time to time.
And Cloud Functions, with
the stateless execution
of horizontal scalability.
On BigQuery-- BigQuery is a
tool that we leverage a lot.
The SQL nature,
the ability to see
data in very cost
effective queries,
is a platform that we really
developed to really see
what we were trying to build.
And it enabled
quite a few things.
It enabled us to
really dive deep
and try to visualize
what we wanted
to create in applications.
And identify data
integrity issues.
Is our devices-- do they
have issues with the metrics
that they're streaming?
And it helped identify missing
metrics for the capabilities
that we're trying to capture.
And this is a milestone that
allowed us to iterate and do
full stack changes in a
pretty efficient manner.
So as we start seeing more
metrics and ingesting them,
we can work with that
without really impacting
the rest of the stack.
The next piece that's
pretty critical that
for us, has been a
challenge and is one
that we're excited to continue
to work on, is data processing.
So for our messages
from vehicles,
these are very specific
events in time.
I mean, we need to process that
and start having some higher
abstractions.
For us, that's trips.
That's seeing a individual, a
driver, for a window of time,
go to different locations.
It's trips.
And it's the insights that
we want to show about trips.
Specifically, that
I'll get to when
I show off a little
bit of mission control.
With data processing,
we actually
went through a couple
of iterations of it.
It was definitely
a learning for us
on how to do this
cost effectively.
And there's quite a few tool
sets that we haven't leveraged
yet that we have in our future.
When it comes to the
actual applications itself,
this is a little bit more
of in our wheelhouse,
this is what we've been
developing for years.
So it's really the data
architecture pipeline
that, at least for us
with our experience,
has been a great
learning experience.
For mission control,
this is our dashboard.
This is our web application.
And what you're seeing here
is our first insights that we
built. The graph
in the upper left
is showing insights
on engine idle time.
This is a fleet.
And the graph shows the
total amount of time vehicles
were idling each day.
It's a very simple,
powerful visualization.
And for this
specific use case, we
have a positive outcome of
the idle time decreasing.
This is caused by a
couple of effects.
One is leveraging our
ability to upgrade
the software on vehicles to
help reduce the idle time.
And then the second is just more
visibility and accountability
with individual drivers.
If they understand
their patterns,
they do have an opportunity
to try to optimize that.
Similar to our layered approach
of our whole data architecture
pipeline, it comes
up all the way
to the end user
applications, as well.
When we built this, we didn't
have other visualizations.
We didn't have data processing
that went deeper than this.
And as we added
more capabilities
to mission control, we
continued to add what we need.
This is the sort of
opposite approach.
Instead of insights, this
is going into high fidelity.
And this is looking
specifically at a single chip.
So this is more of a real time
and detailed representation
of our data processing system.
In this one, we're still
highlighting a little bit
of the value out of the
system, with showcasing
not just the GPS locations,
but the amount of idle time
during that trip.
And from that, I'll
pass it back to Jim
to really highlight some
of the lessons learned.
JIM MARTENS: And
not on the demo,
but actually just on the slides.
You got it.
So I think one of
the biggest lessons
learned for us really
had to do a lot with how
best to most cost efficiently
leverage BigQuery.
BigQuery is an incredible
tool to cheaply store data.
It's a great data warehouse.
And it's simple enough
to pull data from it.
But we had multiple systems,
both from trip processing
to just simple mapping,
that we were trying to do.
That at times could
be pulling thousands
of queries in a minute.
We had to change that.
We had to optimize
a lot of the ways
that we both store
data and change data.
If anybody's worked
with BigQuery,
when you start getting into the
terabytes of data on BigQuery,
some of the most important
things to keep in mind
is make sure you use
partition tables,
so that when you're
pulling data in,
you're only pulling
the data you want.
Ultimately, when
it comes to cost,
that's the biggest
thing with BigQuery.
Typically, you don't need
access to all of the data
that you're possibly storing.
For us, that can be
particularly true
when we can have hundreds upon
hundreds of columns of data
that we're storing for any
given event that comes across.
So partitioning,
particularly important.
And making sure that you
leverage your queries
against those partitions.
Sometimes, we still see
that happen within our own,
where, why did that
one cost that much?
Why did that one singular
query cost that much?
So trying to limit that.
Another really great thing to
do is de-normalization of data.
A lot of us come
from the background
of relational databases.
And in that kind of
environment, you're thinking,
oh, joins are no big deal.
We'll do that.
But again, when
you're running lots
of queries against huge data
sets, you don't want that.
You want de-normalized data,
to just have it in one table.
So you're not doing joins
on many, many, many queries.
On top of that, again,
trying to make sure
that you're only pulling the
data that you absolutely need.
StackDriver is your friend.
It's a great way to keep you
from running off the rails.
That's all too easy.
It's all too easy in GCP to
shoot yourself in the foot.
They give you all the power
you're willing to pay for it.
And so using StackDriver,
which they give you,
you can set things up to
keep you on the rails.
And alert you when you've
possibly done something wrong.
Things that we've tried to
avoid, very similar to that,
leverage StackDriver to try
and avoid hitting or going
over quotas before you find
out because your services
have started to stop.
Just shut down because
you've hit your quotas.
And another thing is,
especially in an environment,
it's important that you
have a good DevOps group,
or that you have some sort
of a DevOps operation.
Because again, it's really
easy to set things up
in your environment on GCP.
And you can forget
that they're running
and they're not necessary.
And again-- a lot of the same.
Really leverage the tools
within the infrastructure
to help you keep things in
track with what you expect.
There's a lot of
different services
and they're always changing.
And they're always adding
new features to help you.
Google is really quick
and responsive when
you come into issues that
you need to deal with.
One thing that's been
very helpful to us--
it goes beyond.
There's the initial
billing that you have,
but you can take all
your billing information
and you can load
it into BigQuery.
And you can load
that into Data Studio
and really do deep
drilling to understand
what the costs and usage is
within your entire organization
systems are.
And there's a summary.
I'll pass it back to Marco.
MARCO DELLA TORRE: Jim,
thank you very much.
Yeah, we've actually
just started
piping the data from
billing back into BigQuery.
It's been a huge asset to us.
So maybe that's for future demo.
But we'd really
encourage everyone
out there doing these
kinds of initial builds
to make that one of
your upfront priorities.
It's helped a lot.
Just to run back for a moment.
I know a lot of you are thinking
about or initially building.
We'd encourage you to
look at this architecture
and consider it as a
reference or a resource.
And if it's
something that you're
looking at in terms of
building a connected device
and standing up an
initial architecture,
we'd love to help.
So come talk to us
about our experience.
I think, as Jim said, we
had some lessons learned,
but all in all, it was a
pretty smooth experience.
And especially when
it comes to support,
I think that's one
of the things for me
that I would have changed
about our experiences--
to lean on the Google folks
earlier and more often.
I think we were probably
a little bit overconfident
in terms of building things.
And once we laid on them a bit
more, there was a huge support.
So please take note
of this architecture.
It's working great for us.
And we're extending
it from here.
And if we can help
you with yours,
don't hesitate to reach out.
Just wanted to end on a summary
of our experience, I guess.
We needed a cloud partner.
We had a pretty
amazing opportunity
and a unique differentiator when
it comes to our feature set.
So we went out and
shopped around.
We chose Google for
those three vectors--
speed to launch.
And it has been less
than a year that we
were from a vision on paper
to a platform supporting
some of the largest
fleets in the country.
Support for scale,
which is now something
that we're thankful
for, as we do that.
And then, obviously,
security, which
we didn't have as much time
to touch on, but something
we'd love to talk
about, as well.
We have launched successfully
and with some great user
experiences for drivers and with
dashboards and visualizations,
which we're really
excited about.
And we're growing the business
from there with Google.
We learned a ton, most
notably that the reasons
we selected this platform
and this architecture
actually bore out to be true.
So it's easy to hear
this stuff upfront.
It's really relieving when they
actually turn out to be real.
And with huge support from
the Google Cloud team.
They've really been
pretty amazing about this.
Next up.
We're really excited
about exploring more
of the ML side of the platform.
We're collecting a huge
amount of data now.
And we're doing with it
what we know best, which is,
working with fleets directly,
showing them their reality
and then upgrading their
vehicles to get those benefits.
So they don't have to
rely on driver coaching.
But we're excited
about what we're
going to learn from this data
that we don't already know.
So really excited about that.
And really appreciate
you letting
us walk you through
from our first idea
through the initial
building of the back end,
through to the user experiences
and where we are today.
And happy to answer
any questions
or to just dig in and help
you guys build yours, too.
So thanks for the time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]